أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تعال إلى
[موسيقى] فصل
أجنبي [موسيقى
] [موسيقى] [موسيقى] [موسيقى
] [
موسيقى]
كأطفال
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
اليوم
[موسيقى]
احصل على المزيد من الأغنيات
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شكرًا لك ،
أتمنى أن تكون سعيدًا
بأجنبي
[موسيقى]
فقط تذكر
أنك يجب أن تفكر دائمًا مرتين
[موسيقى]
تغادر  العواطف
[الموسيقى]
وعندما تكون بالخارج ، نعم
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
لأنك تحتاج إلى
[موسيقى]
لتتذكر
أنني أريد أن أكون هكذا
منذ أن كنت صغيرًا منذ ذلك الحين
وليس هناك مصادفة
ليس هناك مصادفة
[موسيقى]
حبيبي ، أنا أمدح
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
حبيبي ،
أنت مجنون ربما نحن طفل [موسيقى
]
أنا طفل مجنون
[موسيقى]
أجنبي
[موسيقى  ]
ربما يومًا ما يا
حبيبي
[موسيقى]
الأغنية التالية هي أغنية العمل ، إنها
مفيدة ، فلنستمتع بها معًا [
موسيقى] أجنبية ،
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق] [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى  ]
[موسيقى]
أجنبية [
موسيقى] [
موسيقى] [موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
[  تصفيق]
أجنبية [
موسيقى
] [تصفيق
] [موسيقى] [
تصفيق] [موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق] [
موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سأطير غدًا
أخذ هذا الوقت وراء ظهري
إذا كنت أتحدث إلى نفسي في الليل
لأنني لا أستطيع أن أنسى
[موسيقى] أجنبية
بالنسبة لك
ولكن هذا ما سأفعله
ورسالة
[موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
[  موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أجنبية